SITUATION.
ALL OF THAT ON THIS DAY.
CHIEF WHITE HOUSE
CORRESPONDENT JOHN ROBERTS
FALLING ALL THE DEVELOPMENTS
AS HE DOES FROM THE NORTH
LAWN OF THE WHITE HOUSE.
GOOD EVENING, JOHN.
>> BRET, GOOD EVENING TO
YOU.
LET'S START FIRST OF ALL
WITH DR. RONNIE JACKSON.
TO HEAR THE WHITE HOUSE TELL
IT DEMOCRATS WERE OUT TO
DESTROY THE CAREER OF A GOOD
MAN.
THE DEMOCRATS SAY THE
PRESIDENT SHOULD HAVE KNOWN
BETTER THAN TO SEND THEM A
NOMINEE THAT WOULD NEVER BE
CONFIRMED.
UPSHOT OF ALL OF THIS
DR. RONNY JACKSON HAS
WITHDRAWN HIS NAME FROM
CONSIDERATION.
AND THE PRESIDENT IS NOW
LOOKING FOR A NEW NOMINEE TO
BE V.A. SECRETARY.
>> LET'S GO.
WE ARE GOING TO THE OVAL
OFFICE.
>> SIGNING AUTOGRAPHS FOR
CHILDREN ON TAKE YOUR KIDS
TO WORK TODAY, PRESIDENT
TRUMP TODAY UNLEWDED ON
CRITICS WHO FORCED VETERANS
AFFAIRS NOMINEE DR. RONNY
JACKSON TO WITHDRAW.
>> HE'S A GREAT MAN AND HE
GOT TREATED VERY, VERY
UNFAIRLY.
HE GOT TREATED REALLY
>> IN A STATEMENT,
DR. JACKSON DENIED THE DRAWN
DRY LIST OF ALLEGATIONS
DEMOCRATS HAD AMASSED
AGAINST HIM SAYING I
EXPECTED TOUGH QUESTIONS
ABOUT HOW TO BEST CARE FOR
OUR VETERANS.
BUT DID I NOT EXPECT TO HAVE
TO DIGNIFY BASELESS AND
ANONYMOUS ATTACKS ON MY
CHARACTER AND INTEGRITY.
THE SENATE MINORITY LEADER
SAID IF ANYONE TO IS TO
BLAME THE MAIL STRUM AROUND
DR. JACKSON IT'S PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
>> THE PRESIDENT IS WHAT
CAUSED THIS PROBLEM BY NOT
PROPERLY VETTING, BY MAKING
THESE DECISIONS ON THE FLY,
BY MAKING SURE THEY DON'T
COUNT.
>> AS THE JACKSON WITHDRAWAL
WAS STILL SETTLING, THE
PRESIDENT'S EMBATTLED E.P.A.
ADMINISTRATOR WAS IN THE HOT
SEAT IN CONGRESS.
BOMBARDED WITH QUESTIONS
ABOUT POLITICAL FAVORS AND
EXCESSIVE SPENDING ON
TRAVEL, SECURITY, AND THE
SECURE PHONE BOOTH.
>> UNFIT TO HOLD PUBLIC
OFFICE AND UNDESERVING OF
THE PUBLIC TRUST.
>> PRUITT INSISTED THE
CHARGES AGAINST HIM ARE WAY
OVERBLOWN.
>> HALF TRUTHS ARE AT BEST
STORIES THAT HAVE BEEN SO
TWISTED THEY DO NOT
REACCEPTIBLE REALITY.
>> PERHAPS ONE OF THE MOST
CONTROVERSIAL ISSUES FACING
PRUITT, HUGE RAISES THAT
WERE GIVEN TO TWO E.P.A.
STAFFERS AGAINST THE
DIRECTION OF THE WHITE
HOUSE.
IN A FOX NEWS INTERVIEW,
PRUITT DENIED ANY KNOWLEDGE
OF THE RAISES OR WHO
APPROVED THEM.
>> SO WHO DID IT?
THERE WOULD BE
ACCOUNTABILITY.
PERSON?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
>> YOU DON'T KNOW?
YOU DON'T KNOW ANYTHING.
YOU DON'T KNOW WHO DID IT.
>> PRUITT ADMITTED TODAY HE
GAVE HIS CHIEF OF STAFF THE
AUTHORITY TO GRANT PAY
INCREASES AND KNEW THE TWO
STAFFERS WANTED RAISES.
HOWEVER, PRUITT SAYS HE
DIDN'T NOTE DETAILS.
>> ONE OF THE AIDS WHO
RECEIVED A SUBSTANTIAL RAISE
STATED YOU WERE AWARE OF AND
SUPPORTED THE RAISES.
WAS THAT TRUE?
>> I THINK WITH RESPECT TO
THE RAISES.
>> WAS THAT TRUE.
>> WAS NOT AWARE OF THE
AMOUNT NOR WAS I AWARE OF
THE BYPASSING OR THE PPO
PROCESS NOT BEING RESPECTED.
>> IN A MORNING PHONE
INTERVIEW WITH "FOX &
FRIENDS," PRESIDENT TRUMP
TODAY PUT THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE ON NOTICE.
START INVESTIGATING CHARGES
LEVELED AT HIS OPPONENTS HE
SAID OR HE MIGHT JUST STEP
IN.
>> I HAVE DECIDED THAT I
WON'T BE INVOLVED.
I MAY CHANGE MY MIND AT SOME
POINT BECAUSE WHAT'S GOING
ON A DISGRACE.
IT'S AN SALUTE DISGRACE.
>> AFTER DENYING ANY
KNOWLEDGE OF THE STORMY
DANIELS PAYOFF, FOR THE
FIRST TIME TODAY PRESIDENT
TRUMP APPEARED TO
ACKNOWLEDGE MICHAEL COHEN
WAS WORKING ON HIS BEHALF.
>> HE REPRESENTS ME LIKE
WITH THIS CRAZY STORMY
DANIELS DEAL, HE REPRESENTED
ME AND, YOU KNOW, FROM WHAT
I SEE, HE DID ABSOLUTELY
NOTHING WRONG.
>> AND A NEW DEVELOPMENT
TODAY IN THE CASE OF ROB
PORTER, THE FORMER STAFF
SECRETARY HERE AT THE WHITE
HOUSE WHO WAS FIRED BACK IN
FEBRUARY IN A LETTER TO
CHAIRMAN TREY GOWDY THE FBI
SAYS IT FIRST SENT OVER
DEROGATORY INFORMATION ABOUT
ROB PORTER ON MARCH 3RD OF
2017.
THAT DEROGATORY INFORMATION
FILE WAS ADDRESSED TO DON
MCGAHN, THE WHITE HOUSE
COUNSEL'S OFFICE.
THE WHITE HOUSE CONTINUES TO
INSIST IT DID NOT LEARN
ABOUT THE ALLEGATIONS THAT
PORTER ABUSED HIS TWO
EXWIVES UNTIL FEBRUARY 6TH
OF THIS YEAR.
THAT'S NEARLY A YEAR LATER.
WHITE HOUSE OFFICIALS TELL
FOX NEWS THAT MCGAHN NEVER
SAW THAT FILE BUT NO ONE
COULD EXPLAIN WHY.
BRET?
>> Bret: JOHN, IT WAS
CLEARLY A BUMPY RIDE FOR
SCOTT PRUITT UP ON CAPITOL
HILL.
IS THERE A SENSE BEHIND THE
SCENES THERE THAT HIS FUTURE
HAS CHANGED IN THE EYES OF
THE WHITE HOUSE?
>> I DON'T KNOW IF THIS
CHANGES THINGS TO ANY
GREATER DEGREE THAN THEY
WERE ALREADY AT, BRET.
IT'S NO SECRET AT THE WHITE
HOUSE THAT THE ONLY PERSON
IN THIS BUILDING WHO
SUPPORTS SCOTT PRUITT IS THE
PRESIDENT.
BUT THEN AGAIN, HE IS THE
ONLY PERSON WHO NEEDS TO.
>> Bret: ONE LAST THING ON
RONNY JACKSON HE GOES BACK
TO HIS FORMER JOB?
IS HE GOING TO STAY THERE?
>> THAT'S A QUESTION.
IS HE CURRENTLY WORKING IN
THE WHITE HOUSE MEDICAL
UNIT, WHEN HE WAS TABBED FOR
THE NOMINATION FOR V.A.
SECRETARY HE CEASED BEING
THE PRESIDENT'S PERSONAL
PHYSICIAN.
AND NOW THEY ARE WRESTLING
WITH THIS IDEA OF COULD HE
GO BACK TO THAT POSITION
WITH THE CLOUD OF
ALLEGATIONS HANGING OVER
HIM.
BUT THEN AGAIN, IF HE SAYS
NONE OF IT WAS TRUE AND IT
WASN'T TRUE, WHY SHOULD THAT
PREVENT HIM FROM GOING BACK.
BUT, AT THIS POINT, NOBODY
HAS LAUNCHED AN
INVESTIGATION TO TRY TO
CLEAR ALL OF THIS UP.